let me ask the big question i
apologize for the absurd romantic nature
of it uh
outside i mean one of the things the
fact that you've
laid your eyes on a ufo
probably open your eyes to the
possibility that some of the other
sightings
there there could be other sightings
that have legitimacy to them
what to use the outside of your own
sighting
is the most interesting sighting or
ufo related event in history
uh i think there's several what is it
ramishine forest in england
uh the u.s guys that saw stuff and
actually got radiation burns one guy was
medically disabled but
they weren't going to give it and he had
help from jim carr john mccain
his office helped get the guy's uh
disability reestablished
i think that's a big one i think there's
people out there that have seen stuff
and i'm talking credible uh because
there's you gotta remember
there's a huge chunk of these sightings
that get disproven they're they're
actually explainable
yeah uh you know you had sent me the
question
the the phoenix lights i think there's
what's that so i'm sorry i'm not
familiar with some of these the the
uh i'm not either it's i want a funny
story on that so i was at a i was at a
conference and
hopefully he doesn't watch us to get
offended but we had this uh
this it was i call it speed dating so
there's a table there's about eight
people at a table yeah
and we would go sit at the table and
they could ask us questions and then
after ten minutes we moved to the next
table yeah
so i was speed dating all these people
that are really into this yeah it was
kind of funny but
i sat down and it's always funny because
some people will try and dominate it but
you know you have to kind of push the
dominators away so that you know if
you're quiet and introverted you can ask
your question too
so we got into this and the guy starts
naming all these well what about this
what about the phoenix lights i'm like i
don't know about the phoenix lights what
about this event i don't know about that
he goes
he looks at me he goes well you're not a
ufo guy i go
no i'm not but i chase one so i'm an
expert have you
and you could see him get deflated
because i'm kind of a smart ass like
that
yeah i mean that firsthand experience
from a credible
in some sense these sightings have to do
both with the evidence
and the human well i think part of that
is to us
that's a credibility piece because the
four of us that actually saw it plus
you know the other two that were in the
airplane that shot the video
none of us are ufo obsessed people so
when we come out and say because to me
it's just an it's five minutes of my
life
i mean i did a lot of really cool i've
had a really kind of neat things i've
been able to do um
but when you look at it and go
we don't it to me it wasn't it's not the
pinnacle of my life
you know to other people that they live
in the ufo world and
it's like they you know if you talk to
people they'll go that are really into
it who've never seen one
it kills them that they didn't see one
when here we are because and what's
unique with ours which kind of adds that
level is it wasn't we just didn't see it
it wasn't like oh look something in the
sky and it was weird we actually engaged
with it
you know it was yeah that was an engaged
five-minute thing and there's other
stories from other countries like
there's a story uh in the back in when
the soviet union existed
that they actually would chase these
things and one of them shot at some you
know it shot it
because they said shoot at it and it
shot it and then it got shot down
and then they said don't ever shoot at
them again and don't chase them just you
can observe them but don't go after them
because obviously they have firepower
that we can't control because if you can
make something float around and jam
radars at will and do whatever you want
you know modern terrestrial weapons are
probably
not very useful you know you can go to
independence day they had that force
field around oh we gotta we gotta now
you gotta cyber warfare you gotta take
the bug down you gotta take the warfare
so now we can actually
inhibit some type of damage so there's a
i mean you mentioned the phoenix slices
somebody on i think reddit said uh
ask him any thoughts on mass ufo
sightings like the phoenix lights so
the interesting thing like you said with
the tic tac is that multiple people
laid their eyes on this what what are
your thoughts about the phoenix flights
what are
many people here's the deal with massive
sightings
so the phoenix lights is unexplainable
although i know the air force had said
something about it was an a10 drop in
flares
no i don't think so yeah oh yeah flares
don't burn that long they just come out
and they
you know they detract and they go away
although on the other hand there's you
know because
clouds can do things so so i lived in
central california for 18 years
and you would get oh my god what was
that in the sky and it was really
vandenberg shooting a missile off you
know they were doing icbm tests at one
time where they shoot from vandenberg
and they fly across
and they go land in the atoll at
kwajalein you know and then they can
check the displacement the accuracy and
all that stuff you know it's stuff that
we do because we're a superpower
but when you see them go up you know
especially if you've ever watched a
rocket really launch on a clear night
it'll have the stream the glow and you
can tell it's a rocket but if you don't
look up until later
when it starts to get to the outer edge
of the atmosphere where the
plume coming out of the engine is not
constrained but you can watch this on tv
when leaving the spacex ones go
it's nice and narrow narrow narrow and
then it hits a point where it really
starts to go up and it starts to come to
the sides because there's
the forces aren't holding that all into
one unique thing
and it looks really odd and then it'll
go off
because it burns out and then you get
stage separation then you see the next
one go off and then it's gone
um and people don't understand that
because they didn't watch it from launch
because we used to sit in our driveway
and you know vandenberg is it was a
three hour drive but you could sit and
watch it go you knew they're launching
at night you'd watch
you could watch things really cool if
you don't see anything what you see is
the weird clouds from the exhaust plume
you know what's left the residue that's
sitting in the atmosphere and it and the
wind starts blowing us you get these
really kind of weird shapes in the sky
you know that's part but when you go to
phoenix lights and you go hey you know
when a thousand people see something
you're gonna discredit all a thousand
people or you're gonna try and explain
it away with something else
you know you know the big it's a weather
balloon
you know it's a weather balloon again
just like the tic tac i think is
just inspiring for
the limitless nature of the science
i think you're i think more is going to
come out i think uh some of the stuff
that
the to the stars folks have done uh so
there's the
stars academy yeah what are your
thoughts about them are they
um i talk to him quite a bit um i am not
a part of to the stars academy i
you know but you know like i talked to
lou i just was texting him
before this yeah so he they're what's
their mission what's their hope what's
their what's there when they started
their mission was to try and
don't look at this as little green men
but let's look at this as a technology
and let's try and almost reverse
engineer and figure out how these things
operate and
how can we explain this from using our
knowledge you know physics-based
knowledge to go how would something like
this operate
that's really their bottom line was to
try and use and then
couple that with because they've got the
series unidentified
a couple that with television
to get the word out so you're actually
putting something instead of
because everyone has a theory you know
ancient aliens covers all kinds of
theories
you know it's kind of off of oh my god
and i've seen the stuff and i've seen
stuff that i've said taken out of
context on shows that i did not talk to
uh so there's all that because you can
take a clip and go oh it's this
it's that you know if i know about stuff
like you can't technically use my
likeness unless i tell you you can
so if i haven't signed something you
can't do there was a guy who put
something out and i was in it and i told
him you can take it down and you talk to
lawyers because i'm not
i'm not supporting you and they use it
to tell some kind of narrative that this
is
not connected to realize let's face it
if you're making tv shows
there's two reasons to do it one you
want to get word out or two you want to
make money
or three both and so usually it's i
would say the
make money is probably the biggest thing
to put a tv show out
and the the mission of the to the stars
academy academies to not do that
this is is to try to get some
when i when i started and i talked to
them because i've talked to tom and i've
talked to
lou and those are the two main players
it was to
basically demystify the fact and get rid
of the
the stigma that's tied to ufos and let's
look at it from a science base and then
use tv to get the word out on the
progress
and they've done some pretty cool things
i mean you know they've the the italian
government gave them all kinds of files
that
had been you know property their
government they got a bunch from
it might have been argentina gave them
all kinds of stuff like here's all our
records what can you do with it to try
and now pull
from country based to a more global
based research which is what you were
talking about
and then using independent scientists
that are not tied to a government
i mean any government but just using
independent research agencies to start
looking at some of the metallurgy
because you go oh i found this we had
this piece of metal what is it and some
of the stuff has been explained they've
got some objects artifacts that have not
been explained
and that's slowly coming out you know
and i think uh
and you hope is the us government will
release well the government is the
government the us government came out
a month ago and said we have we have we
have material that we cannot explain the
origin
they have said that they just haven't
released the wreckage from the roswell
thing which i keep joking about i'm like
come on it's 70-something years old
i mean let it out i think he put it
beautifully
that in this time that would be a heck
of an inspiring hopeful thing to see
like people don't just to distract them
yeah the division is
i mean nothing will unite us humans
descendants of chimps uh
like uh the idea that there's life out
there oh
it would literally change because i said
this a while ago i forget i think as the
london sun times had called me and i
said you know personally i think this is
a global issue it's not
if there is stuff coming down which
we're pretty sure there is there's
enough stuff that we can't explain
if there is stuff coming down then this
is not a country based thing and it's
not about technology and it's not about
who's going to win the next war
because you don't know what they're
doing so you got really
a couple of theories one you've got et
or close encounters and the other
extreme is you've got independence day
are you going to prepare and bet on et
and close encounters
or do you actually try and do stuff in
case it is independence day you actually
have a game plan
and when you get into independence day
that scenario
you know and i don't like going too much
into sci-fi but
let's just say in theory that that
becomes a reality it's not a u.s
russia china england france spain
name any country and any continent it
becomes a global issue
and the only way you can deny it's just
like americans we all
you know we're divided it it's it's been
that way forever so if you think we
won't get through this we'll get through
it because we've had times just like
this before
until nazi germany pops up but if nazi
germany pops up or someone flies two
airplanes into the world trade center
and then all of a sudden we're all like
united we also have
very very short memories yes we do
exactly it's when you look and go uh
well
we can do this and you go no no if if
you think
that everyone on the planet is good
you need to stop taking the drugs that
you're taking you know we said this
there were people during
the rise of hitler no no it's it's okay
no no it's okay we're not gonna do we're
not gonna stop no no it's okay no no
it's okay
and you gotta think the only thing that
stopped hitler
was his ego by going into russia
if he just stuck with the pact with
stalin and not went to the east and had
to fight and it was really the russian
winner that crushed him
and he would have put all his high
troops to the other side
there would have been a totally
different outcome the man in the iron
the man in the high tower or whatever
it's a netflix show where
nazi actually wins it and you look you
know we didn't know
everything that was going on especially
the atrocities with the concentration
camps and what he was doing to
to the jews i mean it's you look at that
going if you really want to see evil and
then there's the whole side of what
stalin did because he actually
exterminated more people than hitler did
but that never gets the press and the
thing is
we forget this we forget this history
in our conflicts today we forget that
there is the nature of evil we
forget that there's real evil in the
world and
um the thing to fight that evil is to be
united to be
uh both it's like this interesting line
like you talked about joe rogan of being
both
like kind to each other compassionate
empathetic
but also being like strong
and a bad [ __ ] when you need to
to make sure that you
that like there's a it's a balance
between kindness and force
that is you you use force when force is
necessary
but you don't have to walk around like
billy badass all the time i mean some of
the toughest people that i grew up with
that literally could kick the [ __ ] out
of whoever came near him
they never got in fights because one
even people that didn't know them
because they were actually
nice guys you know they were they're
just good dudes
but you know if you cross them like i
had a friend of mine uh
he was he's a nationally ranked wrestler
he went to went to naval academy with me
he's a very very good friend of mine
um and uh he is when you meet him
and he wrestled at 190 pounds and he did
not lose a match his senior year until
he went to nationals he just had a bad
day he actually lost to a guy he had
pummeled the [ __ ] out of
and he would cross it was funny we we
joke about it even with him because when
you meet him he's like the nicest like
lo go
hey hey dude you know hey how you doing
he's super nice he would cross that ring
on on a wrestling mat as soon as he
crossed that ring
it was like a totally different person
and he would go out there and just
destroy people
i mean physically destroy like put a
hurt on
and he would get done and he's like
super humble and they'd raise his hand
and he would he'd have this blank
expression they'd raise his hand and
he'd walk off and as soon as he crossed
the line
he'd he'd look up and swing hey hi guys
how you doing like he literally just
went and could rip someone's arms off
but as soon as he crossed line he's a
totally different person he's like
and he's that way today yeah he won't
even tell you he's a wrestler yeah
that's kind of a symbol of the best of
america
that's what america is oh he's that
wrestler he's across the line
you're you're uh you could be hard but
once you're off the mat you're just a
kind human being
you